The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons License.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
education resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional material
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: Okay.
Hi.
So, our goal, certainly,
to reach next week
is partial
differential equations.
Laplace's equation.
Additional topics still
to see clearly in 1-D.
So one of those topics,
these will both come today,
one of those topics is the idea,
still in the finite element
world, of element matrices.
So you remember, we saw those,
that each bar in the truss
could give a piece of A
transpose A that could be
stamped in, or assembled,
to use the right word --
I think assembled is maybe used
more than stamped in, but both
okay -- into K. For graphs,
an edge in the graph gave us
a little [1, -1; -1, 1] matrix
that could be stamped in.
And now we want to see,
how does that process work
for finite elements.
Because that's how finite
element matrices are really
put together, out of
these element matrices.
Okay, so that's step one,
that's half today's lecture.
Step two, problem two now,
coming from the next section,
is fourth order equations.
Up to now, all our
differential equations
have been second order.
Are there fourth order
equations that are important?
Yes, there are.
For beam bending.
So I'll describe that
application, which leads
to fourth order equations.
Do they fit our A
transpose C A framework?
You bet.
You know they will.
Each additional application
in the framework kind of
gets us comfortable,
familiar with that framework,
what it can do.
The A transpose C A.
So let me start with
element matrices.
I'll get the homework,
those numbers
will get posted on the
website later today.
I just thought
I'd put them down,
and I have to figure out what
would be a suitable MATLAB
question.
So my idea for this
homework, as it really
was for the last
homework, was that you
get some, not a large number
of ordinary questions, paper
and pencil questions,
and one MATLAB question.
When I wrote "MATLAB last",
people interpreted that
as "last MATLAB".
But those words are
not commutative.
Right?
I just meant -- and it
doesn't really matter,
it was a dumb thing to say --
I meant you to put the MATLAB
question at the end after
the regular questions.
Sorry.
So that MATLAB is
due-- Maybe a bunch
of those turned in on Monday
didn't include the MATLAB.
No penalty.
I'm talking now about the
MATLAB for the trusses.
How many have still got a MATLAB
for the truss still to turn in?
A number.
Oh, not too many.
Okay.
Anyway, just when you can.
In my envelope is good.
Okay.
So it'll be a similar
thing for this week,
and because it's
short I said okay,
let's get that
cleaned up by Monday.
And then we're ready for vector
calculus, partial differential
equations, two and three
dimensions, the next big step.
If I want to illustrate
element matrices,
the best place I
could do it would
be to go back to our piecewise
linear elements in 1-D,
and see how an
element now is just
one of those little intervals.
Little pieces of
the whole structure.
If it's a bar, or whatever it
is, I've cut it into pieces.
Here's one piece,
here's another piece.
With finite differences,
if I gave you
unequally spaced meshes,
if my little h is
different from my big H,
we'd have to think again.
I mean there would be
some three-point-- Instead
of minus one, two, minus one
for the second difference,
it would be a little
lopsided, of course,
when the mesh is unequal.
We would have to think that
through for finite differences;
for finite elements, the
system thinks for us.
So I just want to
show how that happens.
So I'll take this.
What's the element matrix
for our standard equation
for that element?
Okay.
And then it would fit
into the big matrix
K. I'm going to come
up with a matrix K
that I could do
in any other way,
but this is the way
it's really done.
So I look in that interval.
I'm focusing on that interval.
So here I've drawn
the basis functions.
But now I'm not going to operate
so much with basis functions.
Let me just think about
that interval again.
That's the same interval.
So those were the
basis functions
that went up to height one.
One started at height
one and went down,
one started at height
zero and went up.
But it's their
combination, of course.
Let me number this node number
zero and this node number one.
So we have some
height, U_0, here.
This is coming from
U_0 times that hat.
And some other
height, U_1, here,
which is coming from
U_1 times that hat.
But inside this interval, my U
in this interval is U_0 times
that first hat function, the
phi_0, the coming down hat.
Plus U_1 times the phi_1
function, the going up hat.
It's a linear function,
so it's going to be there.
That's my graph-- No.
Yes.
This is U(x).
U(x).
Okay.
Right?
I'm focusing inside one element.
One interval.
I've numbered them zero
to one, but of course
that distance is H.
Okay, so there's my function.
Right?
Everybody agrees that
this combination,
it starts out right, it ends
up right, at height U_1,
and it's linear.
So that's got to be right.
So really, what's the
contribution from that element?
I look at the quantity,
that-- And I'm always
taking the phi functions
to equal the V functions.
So I can write this as c(x)
times dU/dx squared, dx.
Over the whole thing, over
the whole interval, that
would be the U
transpose K U. This,
everybody remembers
the K part, of course,
comes from the left
side of the problem.
It comes from integrations.
And this d-- U is now a
combination of all the--
With weights U_0, U_1, U_2, U_3.
If I plug in for capital U
and do all the integrals,
I'll see what K is.
Now what's the point?
The point is, when I
did those integrals,
the question is, how am I
going to do the integrals?
Do I do them-- The way I
did before, was I watched
what phi_0, one phi times
another phi and I integrated.
That was successful.
But the new way is, integrate
it an interval at a time.
Do the integrals.
So this would be K_global.
Now I'm going to go
just from zero to H.
If I go from just zero
to H, that's going
to give me the K_element piece.
The little piece that comes
from this little interval.
And on that little interval,
this is my formula for U.
I'm just hoping you'll sort of
see this as a reasonable idea,
and then when we do the
integral you'll see it.
It clicks.
Okay, how does it click?
So what's my plan?
My plan is, here's my function.
There is its picture.
I'm just going to
plug it into here.
Oh, it's going to
be simple, isn't it?
What's the slope of that
function in that element?
On that interval?
What's the dU/dx?
So instead of doing every full
integral for each separate phi,
I'm doing every element
integral for both phis.
See, these two phis are both
coming in to that element.
Okay, so what's dU/dx.
I didn't realize how neat
this that's going to be.
So what's dU/dx in this element?
I'll use a different board here.
So it's an integral,
then, from zero
to H of whatever
my c(x) might be.
And I'll make a comment on that.
But my focus here
is, what's dU/dx?
What's the derivative?
And then I'm going to square it.
For this function,
for that picture,
the slope is obviously
(U_1-U_0)/H. Right?
The slope is (U_1-U_0)/H.
And I'm squaring it. dx.
Okay.
Let me take c(x)=1.
Just to see clearly
what's going on.
So c(x) is just going to be one.
Okay, so I'm claiming that
this is my U transpose.
My little piece.
Why is it only a little piece?
Because it only
involves two of the U's.
It's going to be a little two
by two element matrix, that
comes from this element.
And then it's going to to be put
into the big K, the global K,
in its proper place.
Okay, well.
It's trivial, right?
This is a constant,
this is a constant,
the integral is just H
times U_1-U_0, squared,
over H squared.
Because that's getting
squared, the interval was
length H. I think
I just have a 1/H.
So this is my U
transpose K element U.
And now I want to pick
out, what's that matrix?
What's that little two by two
matrix that only touches these
two U's?
What's the matrix-- Well,
since it only touches
these two U's, you can tell me.
I want a [U 0, U 1].
Sorry, let me make
a little more space.
And you can tell me what
matrix goes in there.
I want this all to
match up. [U 0, U 1].
Now here is the two by two
element matrix. [U 0, U 1].
What's the two by two
matrix that will correctly
produce this answer?
I'm just shooting
for that answer.
What do I have here?
This is U_1 squared minus
2U_0*U_1, plus a U_0 squared.
Right?
And I have to remember the
1/H, so it's automatically
going to come out right.
So there's a 1/H, shall I
remember that first off.
1/H is part of my
element matrix.
And then, what are the numbers
that go inside that matrix?
We had practice with this.
You remember when
we talked about
positive definite matrices,
way back in chapter one?
The point was that we could
look at eigenvalues, or pivots,
or something.
But the core idea was energy.
The core idea was that
energy, that quadratic,
and that's what we're
looking at again.
That's the energy.
That's the energy, right
there, and this is the energy,
this is the energy in the
finite element subspace.
All I'm saying is, what
matrix, what two by two matrix,
goes with U_1 squared minus
2U_0*U_1 plus U_0 squared.
Just tell me what to
put in that matrix.
What do I put in here?
One, right.
Because it's
multiplying U_0*U_0.
What do I put there?
Minus one.
Good.
Because I have a minus
two, it comes in, minus one
comes in twice, and
a one goes there.
So there, with the
1/H included, is K_e.
K_element, for that element.
For the big H element.
You'll say big deal, because
we've seen this thing before.
Notice what is nice.
First of all, notice
how nice that is.
It's particularly
nice, of course,
because I took c(x) to be one.
So let me make a comment.
Suppose c(x) was not one.
What would I do?
Suppose c(x), suppose I
have some variable stiffness
in the material.
Suppose the material
could be changing width,
so its stiffness would change.
So in other words, I'd
have a variable, c(x),
that I should do the integral.
Probably finite element
systems aren't set up
to actually do the
exact integral.
What would they do?
They would take, for
that simple integration,
they would probably just
take c(x) at the midpoint.
So there's a
numerical integration
here in the creation of
these element matrices.
And numerical
immigration is just,
take a suitable combination
of the values at a few points.
You do know Simpson's rule?
Simpson's rule, that's a
pretty high level rule.
My suggestion there was
just a midpoint rule.
Just take c(x) at the
middle of the interval.
Then it would factor out.
So I should really put a c here.
A c should really
be coming in there.
And you expected that, right,
from the A transpose C A.
We always saw a C in the middle.
It really should be there.
When I took c to be
1, I didn't see it.
So what am I doing?
I'm approximating
c(x) by c at halfway.
Approximately.
I would replace this unpleasant,
possibly varying function by c
at a point and use that value.
So numerical integration
is one part of the picture
that-- We won't go into
all the different rules.
There's a rectangle
rule, there's
a trapezoid rule, very good.
There's the Simpson's
rule that's better.
As I get higher order elements,
like those cubic elements
I spoke about, the numerical
integration has to keep up.
If I was integrating
cubic stuff,
I wouldn't use
such a cheap rule.
I would go up to Simpson's
rule, or Gauss's rule,
or somebody's rule.
Anyway, that's the c part.
Here's the part that
stamps into the matrix.
Notice, by the way,
when I stamp it in,
tell me how it's going
to look stamped in.
And then I've completed it.
So here's my big K. I wish I
had a little more room for it.
Okay, here's my big
K. So that interval
that I drew there,
the H interval,
will stamp in here,
some two by two.
Right?
Now where will the similar
thing coming from this guy.
So, maybe it has to
be numbered minus one.
Sorry about that.
That's another little interval.
I'll do the same thing
on that interval.
I'll get a little element
matrix, two by two guy,
for K for that element.
And where will it
fit in to the big K?
Does it fit in up here,
let me just ask you.
Does it fit in up there?
Yes, no?
I'm assembling, stamping
in the small two
by twos into the full n by n.
And if I draw the
picture you'll see it.
So when I do the two by two
for that big H interval,
it goes there, let's say,
then I just want to say where
does the two by two go for
the interval to the left?
Does it go there?
Nope.
How does it go?
It overlaps.
Right?
Why does it overlap?
Because the phi_0, this
guy, is acting on the right,
and also acting on the left.
The U_0 is active, is
partly controlling the slope
this way, and also that way.
The U_0 is in common
the two intervals.
Anytime any unknowns, any
mesh points that are in
common to two
elements, we're going
to have an overlap
when we assemble.
And so it'll just sit,
it'll sit right there.
And so there is
the diagonal guy.
And maybe you could tell me
what number will go there.
What number would
actually go there?
And then you'll see the whole
point of assembly, stamping in.
Well, what number
goes there from this?
One times the c/H. So in
here would be the c --
can I call it c_right, or c_H,
c on the big H interval --
divided by the H. Because that
one, we had to get it right.
And then what will go
in that very same spot?
So add it in coming from
the small h interval.
The same thing, it'll be
this one, like shifted up,
moved over.
So it'll be coming
from that one,
so it'll be a c on the little h
interval, divided by little h.
That would be the
diagonal entry of K.
That's what we would
see right there.
Over here, should I
write a typical row of K?
Typical row of K,
when I do that,
is going to have this c_h/h
plus c_H/H. That's like the two,
right?
That's like the two.
And what goes here?
What will the entry be that
sits there when I assemble?
Just this guy.
Right?
Just this guy, times that.
The entry here will be the minus
c_H/H. That'll be the entry.
This is the diagonal one,
this is the one to the right,
and what's the one to the left?
What's the one here?
Well, you know what it is.
It's going to come from the
minus and it'll be the minus c
little h over little h.
Look at that.
That just shows
you how it works.
And again, you can look at that,
page 299 to 300 in the book.
You see that if the c's are the
same, if the h's are the same,
then we're looking again at
our minus one, two, minus one.
Times whatever c over h, to
keep it dimensionally right.
Do you see that?
It's just simple.
Simple idea.
The point is that each interval
can be done separately.
It's a simple idea in 1-D.
It's a key idea in 2-D,
where we have triangles,
we have tetrahedra, tets.
We'll see this in
two dimensions,
later in this chapter, when
we're doing Laplace's equation.
It's just fun to see it work.
You'll have different triangles,
say call them triangles.
So that phi-- Do you
want me to look ahead?
Just ten seconds, to triangles?
So imagine we have triangles
here, so we have piecewise,
we have little pyramids.
Instead of hat functions,
they grow to pyramids.
So there's a pyramid guy
whose height is one there,
and drops to zero
in all these places.
And that's our phi.
Our trial function,
test function,
will be a pyramid
function, then.
And I can do integrals that
way, or I can take the integral
over a typical triangle.
So a typical triangle
is involved with three,
now I've three functions, in
the linear case, controlling
inside that triangle.
So what will be the size
of the element matrix?
Can you sort of see how the
system is going to work?
And then we'll make
it work in 2-D.
Every node, every mesh
point, corresponds,
has a pyramid function,
has a U that goes with it.
Those U's are the unknowns.
And how many of
those unknowns are
operating inside that triangle?
Three.
So what will be the
size of the element
matrix, the non-zero part
of the element matrix?
Three by three.
What else could it be?
So we'll see what it looks like.
And we'll have integrals
over triangles.
So that's good.
Okay, thanks.
Exactly halfway through the
hour is exactly that first topic
of element matrices.
Done.
Okay.
Let me take two deep
breaths, and move
to fourth order equations.
Fourth order equations.
For the bending of a beam.
So I'd better draw a beam.
This is a 1-D problem, still.
To keep it 1-D, this
better be a thin beam.
So this is a thin beam.
And the loads, what's
the difference?
What's here?
It looks like a bar,
pretty much, right?
But the difference is, the
load is acting this way.
The load is acting
that way on the beam.
Maybe two loads.
Maybe a uniform load.
Maybe the weight of the beam.
But it's transverse.
It's in the perpendicular,
it's transverse to the beam.
It's this way.
So the beam bends.
Let me do a fixed-free.
So this'll be a fixed-free beam.
Fixed-free, the
word for fixed-free
would be cantilever beam.
Okay.
So what happens if I
impose those loads.
Well, the beam bends.
So the displacement is
now downwards, is now
not the direction of the rod.
The displacement
I'm interested in
is perpendicular to the beam.
Downwards.
Okay, so we can start
on our framework.
So this is displacement. u(x).
I'll stay with the same letters.
So you know I'm going
to have an A, that
will take me to whatever
this is going to get called.
What's the quantity there?
It's going to be, let's see.
What happens?
So this is just geometric now.
Let me put in the
easy part, C. That'll
be sort of the
bending stiffness.
Right?
This'll be the
bending stiffness.
Because the beam
is going to bend.
And over here I'll
get a suitable w.
What I get here-- So
when the beam bends...
Its curvature.
Curvature of the beam
is what's produced.
It's not stretching of the
beam; it's curving of the beam.
So this quantity, e, will
be the curvature that
comes from the displacement.
If I displace these beams,
suppose I put a load here,
it's going to bend that down.
The bar will curve.
So the curvature e.
Now then, the
question is, what is
this A; what is the curvature?
Well, do you remember?
You're on the ball
if you remember
the formula for curvature.
It's a horrible
formula, actually.
But that's only-- We're
going to make it better.
Do you remember the
curvature, it was in calculus.
Yes, you all remember this.
Suppose I have a graph.
I know its slope, that's
become easy now, right?
Calculus.
But the curvature of it, what
derivative did it involve?
Second derivative.
And was it the second
derivative exactly?
No, unfortunately there's
some term which is horrible.
One plus the first derivative
squared, all square root.
But I'm just going to
take u double prime.
So this is an approximation.
So what is A now?
What's my matrix A, that gets
me from u-- or my operator
A, that gets me from u to e?
What's the e=Au equation?
A is just second derivative.
That's something new.
A is second derivative.
And why do I do that?
Because I assume small
curvature, small displacements.
I assume that u' squared is
very small compared to one.
So it's just slightly bent.
A beam that goes way down
here, I'd have to go nonlinear.
But if I want to keep things
linear, I approximate.
This will be much
smaller than this,
so one is fine, that term goes.
And now the next
step will be easy.
What's the bending moment?
This will be called
the bending moment.
And let me use the
letter w again.
I should really use capital
M for bending moment.
That will be the stiffness
times the curvature.
So that's the force,
the way the spring
had a restoring
force by Hooke's law.
This is the equivalent
of Hooke's law.
But this restoring force
is not pulling back,
it's bending back.
It's torquing back.
And then, of course
you know, there'll
be an equilibrium equation
to balance the load.
So this load is the f(x).
And you know what that'll be.
Because you know it'll
involve A transpose.
And the transpose of that, do
you want to just make a guess?
I shouldn't use transpose, of
course, but I'll use it again.
It'll be the same; it'll
be second derivative.
I mentioned we had a minus
sign with the first derivative,
but now we're going to
have two minus signs,
so it's going to come out
symmetric, second derivative,
and the equation here
will be w''=f(x).
Our framework is working.
We have plus boundary
conditions on u.
And here we have plus
boundary conditions on w.
So those parts we have
not yet mentioned.
And of course, that
depends on my picture.
While we're at it, why don't we
figure out, what do you think
is the boundary condition here?
And how many boundary
conditions am I
going to look for altogether?
Four altogether.
Because I have a
fourth order equation.
There will be four
arbitrary constants
until I plug in
boundary conditions.
So I'm looking for four
boundary conditions,
two at this end,
two at that end now.
And what will be the
two at the fixed end?
At the fixed end,
obviously, it's built in.
Built in.
Slightly different words
sometimes for the beam problem.
Here I'll have u=0 and u'=0.
Those apply with
A; those go with A.
Those are the
essential conditions,
the Dirichlet conditions, the
ones I must impose all the way.
And now at this free
end, what do you think?
Well, it's great.
It's w=0, and w'=0.
It's just beautiful,
the way it all works.
So that's a
completely fixed-free.
Then why don't I draw
in, just while we're
talking about boundary
conditions, an alternative.
So here's my beam.
And now you see, it's under a
load, f(x), transverse load.
Now that would be different
boundary conditions.
Anybody know the name of a
beam that's set up like that?
Simply supported.
You don't need
beam theory, and I
don't know beam theory,
to tell the truth,
to do these problems.
So that's a simply
supported beam.
And what are the boundary
conditions that go with that?
Well this is u=0.
No displacement, it sits
there on that support.
And what else is
happening at that support?
There's no bending moment.
Nobody's here.
Right?
So it's w=0.
And at this end, too.
Also at this end, u at
one is sitting there,
and w(1) is zero.
Yeah.
That would be the boundary
conditions, four of them,
for a fourth order
equation that we'll just
write down in a minute,
for simply supported.
And we could have a mix.
This could be simply
supported here, free here.
I think.
Or maybe, could it be, or
maybe that's too risky.
Would that be a singular
case, simply supported?
Huh.
So as always with boundary
conditions, some are unstable.
Some are not going to
determine all four constants.
Just the way free-free
didn't work, right?
Free-free for a rod
didn't determine anything,
it left a whole rigid motion.
Maybe u=0, w=0 at one end,
and free at the other end,
is that--?
It sounds risky to me.
But we can see.
Okay.
So, do you get the general
picture of the beam?
So what's the equation?
What's A transpose C A,
when I put it all together?
I'll use that space to put in
A transpose C A. Continuous,
we're talking here.
Right now we've got
differential equations.
So what's the differential
equation, A transpose C A?
So it's the second derivative.
I'm just going backwards around
the framework, as always.
The second derivative of this,
and this is c(x) times e(x),
and e(x) is second
derivative of u, equal f(x).
Good.
In ten minutes,
we've written down
the framework, some possible
boundary conditions,
and the combined A
transpose C A equation.
I mean, we're ready to go.
We've got the pattern
to think about this.
So let's see, what
should we do first?
I would say the first thing
to do is, let c be one
and solve some problems.
Let c be one, and
consider-- So if c is one,
it's a fourth
derivative equation.
Should we take uniform load?
Yeah.
How does a beam bend
under its own weight?
So it's just one, or
whatever constant.
So it's constant load,
it's just its own weight,
it's going to sag a
little in the middle.
What's the solution
to that equation?
And what shall I take
as boundary conditions?
Let me do the simply
supported one.
Because that would
be kind of nice.
So it's simply supported, it's
sagging under its own weight,
with u(0)=0, u''(0)=0,
because that's the w.
And u(1)=0, u''(1)=0.
Whatever.
I don't know that
I'll have the patience
to go through and plug in
all four boundary conditions
to determine all four constants.
Just get me to that point.
Get me to a solution
u(x), the general solution
here that's got four
constants in it is what?
Okay.
Okay, think again.
What are we looking at?
We're looking at a linear
differential equation.
Linear problem.
I'm asking for the general
solution to a linear equation.
What's the general set up?
General set up is,
particular solution
plus nullspace solution.
Right?
You see an equation
like that, you're
looking for the
general solution,
tell me one particular
solution and then tell me
all the solutions when
it has zero on the right,
and we've got everybody.
So that was true for matrices,
it was true for Ax=b,
it's just as true for
differential equations.
So what's one
particular solution?
What's one function whose
fourth derivative is one?
Yes?
What am I looking for here?
1/4 of x to the-- No, what?
1/24, is it?
1/24 of x to the fourth?
x to the fourth over 24.
Because four
derivatives-- So we're
thinking we're in the
polynomial world here.
Just as we were with u''.
With the bar it was
x squared over two,
the particular solution, now
we're up to x fourth over 24.
So that's the fourth
derivative is one, good.
So I'm seeing a fourth
degree bending there.
And now what about the
null space solutions,
the homogeneous solutions.
This accounts for the one,
now what are the possibilities
if it was a zero?
You're going to tell me
the whole bunch, right?
A plus Bx plus Cx
squared plus Dx cubed.
Because all of those have
fourth derivatives equal zero.
So that's the general solution.
Okay.
So whatever the
boundary conditions are,
they determine A,
B, C, D. We're not
that far away from Monday's
lecture on fitting cubics.
Actually we're
really close to it.
When we use finite
elements, we're
going to use exactly
those cubics.
I'll get to that point.
Let me take the
other model problem,
that everybody
knows what's coming.
What's the other right-hand side
that this course lives and dies
on-- lives on.
Delta function.
Right.
Delta at some point.
So that's a point load then.
I can make it-- Whatever
the boundary conditions are.
Right.
Good point.
This boring stuff will
just repeat, right?
That's the null space solution.
But now, what is a
particular solution?
The particular solution
has become interesting.
The particular solution here
was straightforward, simple,
a good one to do first.
What's a particular
solution to a point load?
So instead of having
distributed load here,
I'm putting a heavy weight
here at this point, a.
And it's heavy weight, I'm
multiplying the delta function
by one, I could multiply by
some L for load or something,
but let's just keep it simple.
What's a solution to that?
Fourth derivative equals delta.
So that means I've
now got to integrate,
one way to get the
answer here would
be to integrate four times.
Right?
If I integrate delta
four times, then
I've got something whose fourth
derivative will match delta.
So do you remember the
integrals of delta?
Okay, so I integrate.
First integral is: step.
Second integral is: ramp.
Third integral is:
quadratic, right?
This was linear, boop
boop, linear pieces.
The next integral is going to
bring me up to quadratic ramp.
And the next,
fourth one, is going
to bring me up to cubic ramp.
Cubic.
So it's going to be cubic
ramp, is what I get there.
So one particular solution
would be a function that's zero,
and then at the point a, it
suddenly goes up cubically.
So it's zero here, and it's x
cubed over six there, I think.
If I integrate three times,
I'll be up to x cubed over six.
Is that right?
Yes, cubic.
So that's an
interesting function.
Of course, these parts will tilt
the function, will change it.
So our solution
won't look like this,
because I've only got
one particular function,
and I'll need these to satisfy
the boundary conditions.
So there is one
particular solution.
The general solution-- Yes,
good for us to think out
the general solution.
What does that picture look
like when I add in this stuff?
Very, very important.
I'm sorry I don't have
more space for this highly
important picture.
Okay, so here's my point a.
Keep your eye on that point a.
Okay, so to the left of it,
I've got some curve, whatever,
dut dut dut dut dut, the beam.
And to the right of it, I've
got some other curve, whatever
it is, dut dut dut dut dut.
And what's cooking at point a?
What's the jump
condition at point a?
That's the critical question.
What changes at point a?
You remember, this is
the corresponding thing,
the analog of our ramp.
So what changed for
the ramp at point a?
What jumped?
The slope.
Okay, now the question is:
what's going to jump here?
What jumped there?
Here, did the function jump?
Certainly not.
Did the slope jump?
Did the second derivative jump?
No, no.
The second derivative
was zero and then zero.
What jumped?
Third derivative.
The third derivative
is allowed to jump.
And of course.
A jump in the third derivative
produces a delta in the fourth.
Right?
It just works.
So this is a cubic of some
sort, coming from that jump.
This is another, a different
cubic, coming from this sort,
from this junk, and this.
So it's cubic in each piece.
Why is it cubic in each piece?
Because, what's the equation
in the middle of that piece?
What's our differential
equation if I look here?
Here's my equation.
What is it in the middle of
that piece? u fourth equal zero.
The delta function
is zero there.
And u fourth is zero here.
So of course this
is a cubic spline.
We're meeting that neat
word, cubic spline.
Those turn out to be
very, very handy functions
for other things, too.
So we see them
here as a solution
to fourth order equations with
point loads are cubic splines.
Because the big key point is
that there's a jump here in u
triple prime, the
third derivative.
A jump in the third derivative,
that's what we saw here.
And we'll see it if we have
any cubic meeting any cubic.
Let me just say, a jump
in the third derivative,
your eye probably
won't notice it.
I mean, it's a
discontinuity, somehow.
We don't have the same
polynomial from here to here.
But that discontinuity
in u triple prime,
it's pretty darn smooth still.
The slope is continuous, so
your eye doesn't see a ramp.
And even more, the
curving is continuous,
the curvature is continuous.
e and w are good.
It's just a jump in
the third derivative.
Okay, so I want to speak
about splines, and more
about this, and about finite
elements for beam problems
on Friday.
And then that will take care
of 1-D and we'll move into 2-D.
Okay.